gérard vespière merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors les loups
gris se sont fait connaître par le passé
pour des actions violentes notamment à
l'encontre de la communauté kurde ou
arménienne de turquie
représente-t-il une réelle menace sur le
sol français à certains groupuscules
extrémistes donc nous sommes maintenant
bien placés pour savoir que quelques
esprits très radicaux à peuvent aboutir
à des actes a fini mans regrettable
n'est ce pas donc il faut être d'une
plus la plus grande vigilance possible
vis-à-vis de ce groupuscule et dans la
présentation que vous venez de faire il
ya une information intéressante c'est
que ce mouvement d l'oubli est lié au
parti mhp parti tueur politique et
qu'elle est le sol alliés de la cap et
de monsieur erdogan en turquie et bien
c'est le mouvement
m hp alors le pré gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur a donc annoncé
la dissolution de ce mouvement ont il
s'avère qu'en france il n'est pas
structurée sous la loi de 1901
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est
un signal envoyé à la turquie qu'est ce
que représente cette dissolution est ce
que il ya derrière un enjeu diplomatique
à un signal envoyé au pouvoir turc je
crois qu'il faut faire dans tous ces
dossiers dans tous les dossiers goût des
deux cités en dans la présentation une
différence un distinguo entre les
relations franco turques et les
relations entre le pouvoir turc actuel
et la france a le pouvoir turc actuel
est un pouvoir une certaine sensibilité
apolitique à ottomane nationaliste est
donc intéressant internationaliste un
islamiste donc voilà il représente une
partie mais peut-être pas la majorité du
peuple turc et si on en croit les
dernières élections à savoir les
élections municipales
n'est ce pas le parti du président a été
battu dans la capitale juridique de la
turquie quai en carats et dans l'api
capitale économique de la turquie qui
existent en boule d'envoyer ce distinguo
est vraiment très très important à faire
le parti du président est monsieur
erdogan ne sont pas éternels à
nous savons que seuls les diamants sont
éternels
c'est finalement ce que veut dire
l'ambassadeur de turquie en france
quand il déclare le peuple turc est un
grand ami du peuple français
tout à fait il faut savoir que l'analyse
géopolitique que nous faisons ensemble
ce soir
elle doit s'inscrire dans le temps long
or les relations politiques entre la
turquie et la france ont été excellentes
la turquie est membre de l'otan depuis
1953 n'est ce pas d'envoyer vous et la
france était membre fondateur en 49
donc on est dans le temps long et il
faut retrouver ce temps long il y a des
moments de tension liée à des histoires
politiques nationales mais qui devront
se résoudre parce que la grande
faiblesse du pouvoir rade monsieur
erdogan actuellement ce qu'il est seul
il n'a plus d'amis plus d'alliés
vraiment sur la scène internationale pas
d'alliés avec l'europe pas d'alliance
avec les états unis
on connaît le dossier autant les
relations avec la turquie sont
extrêmement dit avec à la russie pardon
avec la russie sont extrêmement
difficiles à la russie via ce bombardé
des camps d'entraînement soutenue par la
turquie en syrie
avec plus de 160 morts et blessés voyez
vous donc les relations sont très très
difficile monsieur erdogan est seul sur
la scène internationale alors toujours
est il que le pouvoir turc a dénoncé une
atteinte à la liberté d'expression après
la dissolution de des loups gris et
annoncé qu'elle répondrait fermement à
telle réponse de la turquie peut-on
s'attendre
aulas je pense qu'il y a d'abord la
première réponse une réponse verbale
la turquie n'a pas forcément beaucoup
beaucoup d'armes à sa disposition pas
beaucoup de cordes à son arc à la france
à d une présence en turquie financières
et industrielles très importantes
donc il ne faut pas non plus négliger
cela 6
devait y avoir des décisions négatives
de la part de du pouvoir politique à
ankara eh bien il pourrait y avoir de
plus en plus de réticence des banques
françaises qui joue un rôle très
important en turquie est aussi dans le
domaine industriel
il ya des constructeurs automobiles
n'est ce pas qui joue un rôle très
important donc la turquie est en
situation économique très difficile au
taux d'inflation au taux de chômage des
taux d'intérêt bancaires à 12%
donc il ne faut pas s'attendre à une
grande rivalité entre la france et la
turquie
à mon sens merci beaucoup gérard
vestiaire pour votre éclairage je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur associé
à la fondation d'études pour le
moyen-orient la faim'' au foie